BRADY HARAN: So we're going to
talk about the number 8,128.
And it's a famous type of number
called perfect number.
Now, this was the largest
perfect number known in
antiquity, or for
very long time.
But what is a perfect number?
The smallest perfect number
is the number six.
So let's look at
the number six.
Now what does it mean?
What divides into six?
Well one divides into six.
That's always true.
Two divides into six.
And three divides into six.
Now, six does divide as well,
but for what we're going to
do, we're going to ignore
the number itself.
So ignore six.
But if we add up the numbers
that divide six--
one, two, and three-- add them
together, and we get the
number six.
We get the number itself.
So this is a perfect number
because the divisors add up to
the number itself.
It's not too small, and
it's not too big.
It's just right.
It's perfect.
And in antiquity, they
were given this
rare, perfect property.
So the next one, after
6, is the number 28.
Let's write that down.
28.
So what divides 28?
Add these together, and
you get the number 28.
It's the second perfect
number.
The third perfect number after
that, bit of a gap after that,
the third perfect
number is 496.
Let's look at the divisors
of this.
And we've got 1.
Quite a few of these.
2, 62, 124, 248.
We're running off the edge.
We add all this together in
the same way as before.
We get 496 again.
It's perfect.
Now, there's only one perfect
number between 1 and 10.
That's the number 6.
There's only one perfect number
between 10 and 100.
That's 28.
There's only one perfect number
between 100 and 1,000--
496.
And there is only one perfect
number between 1,000 and
10,000, and that is 8,128.
Let's try it out then, OK?
1, 2, 4, 8, 2,032, and 4,064.
Add those together in the same
way, and you will get 8,128.
Today, even with our computers
that can compute massive
numbers, we have only found
47 perfect numbers.
That is all.
Four were known to the
ancient Greeks.
Still today, 21st century,
47 we've got.
There may be more.
There may not be.
We don't know if there's
an infinite
many of these numbers.
And that's an open question.
You'd think that that's
something we
would know by now.
Are there infinitely many of
these or aren't there?
We don't know the answer
to that yet.
MALE SPEAKER 2: What's the
biggest perfect number?
BRADY HARAN: So far?
I wouldn't know that.
Let's find out the largest
perfect number.
Well, Wolfram Alpha says, do
you mean largest integer?
There's no largest integer.
So that's helpful.
Interestingly, we don't know
if there are odd perfect
numbers either.
All the perfect numbers we
have found are even.
That's another question
we don't know.
The largest known perfect
number is, apparently,
1,791,000 digits long.
Don't ask me to say it.
We could be here
'til next week.
But that is the full thing.
Nearly 2 million digits long.
I could be scrolling through
this for quite some time.